shark warnings are up in Hawaii this
morning after a deadly attack a witness
says a shark bit off the leg of Thomas
smiley a California man who was swimming
off the coast of Maui on Saturday he
died after rescue attempts on the beach
failed CBS this morning lead national
correspondent David Begg know is in Long
Beach New York on this unofficial start
of summer David how rare are attacks
like this rare Anthony very rare in fact
this is believed to be the first deadly
shark attack for 2019 now there have
been 16 other shark attacks this year
but no one died in that circumstance and
that's according to tracking sharks calm
here's what we know about exactly what
happened in Hawaii beach goers and Maui
watched as dr. Thomas smiley was pulled
from the ocean on the back of the jet
ski
it appeared dr. smiley had been bitten
by a shark while swimming 60 yards off
the beach in Maui
he looked unconscious I saw some blood
on his stomach and it looked like the
skin on his wrist was just torn off and
his entire left leg from his knee down
was just missing first responders
performed CPR but it was too late the 65
year old optometrist who friends
described as a family man with three
kids and six grandchildren died at the
scene he had been vacationing there with
his wife who watched in horror from the
beach we were watching the man get
pulled up we could hear her screaming
she was saying that's my husband that's
my husband Hawaii has the second most
unprovoked shark attacks on record in
the u.s. sitting only behind Florida
four of the last five fatal shark
attacks in the US have occurred in Maui
the last three are all believed to be
from tiger sharks there has been quite a
lot of shark activity in Hawaii in the
last couple of months dr. Michael
Domeier
is director of the marine conservation
science Institute because new laws
protecting some large sharks have caused
their populations to increase he says
swimmers need to be more aware of their
surroundings sometimes we look like prey
and they will check us out so having
something like a white truck or a tiger
even just check you out they have no
hands they only have a mouth could be
disastrous
all right you ocean loving swimmers if
you're in the water experts say if you
ever encounter a shark the best advice
is swim slowly and methodically away
from the shark while keeping your eyes
on the shark the whole time and Gale
they say beyond all don't panic I know
it sounds crazy I would definitely been
that sounds very crazy easier said than
done much easier said than done thank
you very much David bag now